good morning john in your last video you
were talking about how often
stories of great accomplishment are told
as stories of individual genius
rather than like collective progress and
i feel like we've talked a lot about
this on vlogbrothers i wrote like a
couple of books about it
forgive me if i've got a lot of thoughts
about like why this is the case so i
think a lot about teaching and education
and one thing that i know for sure
is that you cannot know everything and
yet we have to understand enough about
the world
and how it works in order to like live
in it and
there are a bunch of different things
that allow us to do that one of those
things is is having access to real
information about the world this thing
is just about the quantity of
information and
it is in general what we think of when
we think of education sometimes we get
so focused on
imparting the quantity of information so
that you have like
all of the necessary data about the
world that we have to simplify a lot of
stuff
and that simplification actually comes
at the cost
of other parts of what is necessary to
sort of like have the tools to live in
the world
let's have an example when it comes to
the invention slash discovery of the
smallpox vaccine
they're like three things that you
should know one smallpox was very bad
but we cured it second we did that with
a vaccine basically that's very much
like the vaccines that we use today that
work by exposing people to an attenuated
form of the pathogen and third
there was a person who figured it out
some way and those first two things are
facts that are important to have in your
head but the third thing is just a story
and i think oftentimes
we simplify stories to make them good so
that we can have like context to hang
these important facts
we do this a lot in education and i
don't think it's a problem simple
stories especially good ones that
fit into established frames that people
are familiar with are really good ways
to help people remember stuff but it
turns out that the story itself
is doing a ton of work in the overall
scheme of what education should be doing
which is like giving you systems with
which to understand
and interface with the world and as i
said a moment ago you may have forgotten
we've been all over the place
quantity of like bits of information is
only one part of education
education also gives us lenses through
which to understand the world and those
lenses
are often stories they also give us
shared lenses shared knowledge
shared values shared world views all
these things help us
live together and work together and
communicate and so it's super worth
asking in what ways
individualist stories serve learners and
by learners i mean human beings and in
what ways they
don't i often find myself on the
anti-individualist side of this debate
but i think that's mostly because like
we focus on that so much this does not
mean that i think people
aren't served by individualist stories i
think we are people should understand
that to some extent we are responsible
for our own faith and that outcomes
are definitely dependent on how hard and
how much and how smart people work not
wholly
of course but in part and i think it's
also really important to note
that like this is more the case for
people who have fewer barriers than for
people who have more barriers and so
individualist stories work a lot better
for folks for whom like myself a lot of
barriers were really low i also think
the focus
only on individualist stories can do
harm you know in part because a lot of
people
can't see themselves inside of them and
not just in the traditional
representation
matters way which it does but like also
just in the way that many people have
barriers that other folks don't have
that's something to fight against but
it's never going to be something that we
are entirely free of and so i think it's
important to like
have stories that recognize the fact
that nobody does anything alone and also
nobody contributes not at all like if
only through conversations we have with
our friends and family everybody adds
something to the human story so
obviously we should fight against the
urge to
individualize every accomplishment that
happened but also we need to teach
people that we are at least to some
extent responsible for our own destinies
we need to remember that the stories we
tell aren't just tools with which to
learn things they are the thing we are
learning and also we should know that
acknowledging or in my case
reveling in the fact that nothing is
possible without the contribution of
millions of people both alive and dead
is good that doesn't lessen individual
accomplishment it should increase our
pride in our ridiculously badass species
john
i'll see you on tuesday